Hi, I'm Mendel,
Product Marketing Manager
for Google Friend Connect.
With Google Friend Connect,
you can easily add social
features to your site.
This means your visitors
can engage more deeply
with your content
and with each other.
Once you start
using Google Friend Connect,
your visitors will
be able to join your site.
Instead of having to create
a new account
with a new password,
they're given
the option of signing in
with their existing Google,
Yahoo, AIM or OpenID account.
This wall gadget
lets your visitors
post comments and start
a discussion on your site.
With this rate
and review gadget,
your visitors
can leave a rating.
New gadgets are constantly
being created by Google
and the OpenSocial
developer community,
so there's an endless number
of other social gadgets
you'll soon be able to add.
Visitors can also engage
with other members of your site.
They can find out
more about them
or choose
to make new friends.
They can even
invite their friends
to come check out your site.
And the best part is that
adding Friend Connect
to your site
takes no programming
whatsoever.
Choose the gadgets
you want from our gallery,
copy and paste
a few snippets of code,
and Friend Connect
does the rest.
So whether you run a blog,
a fan site,
a merchant site,
or a mashup,
your visitors can now
engage more deeply
with your content
and with each other.
Where can you find out more
about Google Friend Connect?
Go to
google.com/friendconnect.